Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The Duke, his aged grandsire, bore the shame till he could bear no more. He rallied his declining powers, summoned the youth to Brackley Towers, and bitterly addressed him thus. Sir, you have disappointed us. We had intended you to be the next Prime Minister, but three. The stocks were sold, the press was squared, the middle class was quite prepared. But as it is, oh, my language fails. Go out and govern
感谢您收听《遗史》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公爵，他年迈的祖父，忍辱负重，直到再也无法忍受。他重振日渐衰退的精力，召集青年们来到布拉克利塔（Brackley Towers），并向他发表了激昂的讲话。先生，你让我们失望了。我们本来打算让你担任下一任首相，但是……股份卖了，媒体被收买了，中产阶级也做好了充分的准备。但现在的局面，唉，我真是无言以对。出去治理
New South Wales. That was Hilaire Belloc, and that's the fate of Lord Lundy in one of his, Belloc's cautionary tales, his poems published in 1907 and of course governing new south wales which is the fate that awaits lord lundy tom that's a fate worse than death for edwardian britain especially being lined up to become prime minister exactly although by 1907 australia had become federated so prime ministers were being elected to run Australia. Yes, we have been thinking a great deal about Australian prime ministers in the last few hours. Speak for yourself, days. I've spent days on Australian prime ministers, prompted by the fact that by the time you listen to this, the Australian general election will
新南威尔士州。那是希莱尔·贝洛克（Hilaire Belloc）的作品，这也是朗迪勋爵（Lord Lundy）在他的一部警世故事诗集中的命运，这些诗出版于1907年，当然，治理新南威尔士州就是等待朗迪勋爵的命运，汤姆，对于爱德华时代的英国来说，这是一个比死亡还要糟糕的命运，尤其是被内定为首相的人。没错，尽管到1907年，澳大利亚已经实行联邦制，所以首相是通过选举产生的来管理澳大利亚。是的，在过去的几个小时里，我们一直在思考澳大利亚首相。请代表你自己，是几天。我花了几天时间研究澳大利亚首相，起因是当你听到这期节目时，澳大利亚大选将
have been held. Elections to the House of Representatives, which is for British listeners, the equivalent of the House of Commons and the Senate, which is the Australian equivalent of the House of Lords. And you will know who has won by this point. Attention. I know. The excitement on the streets of Britain. Whether it's the liberals who are confusingly for again for british listeners basically that the tories or conservatives under scott morrison or uh labor which is labor under anthony albanese i think i've pronounced that right yeah um and so you'll probably know and and i think labor are mildly the favorites aren't they they're marching ahead as at the time that
已经举行。众议院选举，对英国听众来说，相当于下议院，而参议院相当于澳大利亚的上议院。到那时你就会知道谁赢了。注意。我知道。英国街头的兴奋之情。无论是自由党——对英国听众来说，令人困惑的是，基本上就是由斯科特·莫里森（Scott Morrison）领导的托利党或保守党，还是由安东尼·阿尔巴尼斯（Anthony Albanese）领导的工党（我想我没发错音吧），嗯，所以你大概会知道，而且我认为工党稍微占据一点优势，不是吗？正如我们录制这期节目时，他们正领先于民意测验，不是吗？街头巷尾都在讨论这个，汤姆。
we are recording this they're they're just leading opinion polls, aren't they? And the streets are chipping north and Tom. Talking of little else. Little else, exactly. And French presidents prompted by the French presidential elections. And what's interesting is that I would say that to the British and Dominic, we're not apologizing for being British, are we? We are. We're being upfront about that to our many Australian listeners. That Australia seem, you know, Australians seem like kin yeah in so many ways but we're much politically much closer we seem much closer to to france and and germany we have you know merkel and uh schultz and uh macron are political figures in in our consciousness in a way that by and large australian prime ministers have not been that's so interesting interesting, isn't it? Because everybody always thinks that we don't know
除此之外，没别的可聊了。确实没别的了。还有法国总统，这是由法国总统选举引发的。有趣的是，我要对英国听众说，多米尼克，我们可没有为自己是英国人道歉，对吧？我们道歉了。我们在许多澳大利亚听众面前坦诚了这一点。澳大利亚人似乎在很多方面都像亲人一样，但在政治上，我们似乎离法国和德国更近，你知道，默克尔、舒尔茨和马克龙在我们意识中的政治人物地位，是澳大利亚首相大体上所没有的。这太有趣了，不是吗？因为每个人总是认为我们对欧洲了解不够，对欧洲的关注也不够。我们只关心盎格鲁圈（Anglo-sphere）和盎格鲁-撒克逊人的那些事。但实际上，这只适用于美国。我是说，大多数这些名字，说句老实话，在我们开始考虑做这个播客之前，作为一个写20世纪英国历史的书的人，我其实——这是一个可怕的坦白——我以前没听说过其中一些澳大利亚首相。这真的让我想起——一些听众可能还记得，我们曾请过一位叫安德鲁·普雷斯顿（Andrew Preston）的学者，他来过节目好几次，是剑桥大学的教授，一位写过越南战争等题材书籍的加拿大作家。我还记得多年前他告诉我，一位加拿大前首相曾来到伦敦。
enough about Europe, and we're not sufficiently kind of plugged into Europe. And all we care about is the Anglo sphere and Anglo-Saxon carryings on. But actually, that's only truly of America. We don't, I mean, most of these names, I'll be completely honest, until we started thinking about doing this podcast, and speaking as somebody who writes books about 20th century britain i actually this is a terrible confession but i hadn't heard of some of these australian prime ministers and it really reminds me of so some listeners may remember that we had a guy called andrew preston we've had him a couple of times on the show professor at cambridge um a canadian author of books about the vietnam war and so on and i can remember years ago him telling me that a Canadian prime minister had come to London.
前加拿大首相曾来到研讨会。安德鲁非常兴奋。他去了研讨会。在他看来，显然没有人知道这个人是谁，即使在他自我介绍之后也是如此。我说，哦，太糟糕了。人们太无知了。他是谁？安德鲁说，哦，他是乔·克拉克（Joe Clark）。
The former Canadian prime minister had come to the seminar. And Andrew was very excited. And he'd gone to the seminar. And it was patently obvious to him that nobody knew who this man was, even when he introduced himself. And I said, oh, that's terrible. People are so ignorant. Who was he? And Andrew said, well, he was Joe Clark.
我从未听说过乔·克拉克，哪怕在几百万年里我也认不出他，如果他走在街上，我到现在也认不出他。我认为这是英国政治意识中一个非常有趣的空白，我们的英联邦——正如你所说，我们的英联邦亲属——的首相或更广泛的政治在这个国家是完全不为人知的。因此，听到这里的澳大利亚人或加拿大人可能会认为这是英国人的势利和优越感，正如我们这期节目一开始引用的希莱尔·贝洛克的诗所表现的那样。但我觉得有一个更合理的解释，那就是它反映了
And I'd never heard of Joe Clark I wouldn't have recognized him in a million I still wouldn't recognize him if he walked down the street and I think it's a very interesting lacuna in Britain's sort of political consciousness that the prime ministers or the politics more generally of our sort of commonwealth as you say our commonwealth kin are completely unknown in this country so australians or indeed canadians listening to this may assume that this is kind of pommy snobbery and superiority as as evinced by the heller belloc with which we went exactly down this episode yeah but i i think that there's a much more favorable explanation for it which is that it reflects incredibly well
澳大利亚政治的稳定和理性。因为基本上，如果你的领导人没有把他们自己强加到外国人的意识中，这通常意味着他们正在做好工作。而且我认为，当你审视澳大利亚从作为一个流放地建国，到联邦化进程，再到现在的演变时，这其实是一个非常振奋人心的故事。我是说，作为一个板球迷，承认这一点让我感到痛苦。我记得我第一次去澳大利亚时，我是多么渴望讨厌它，结果我却如此深爱它。承认澳大利亚是一个治理得好得多、看起来快乐得多的国家，这让我感到恼火——嗯，澳大利亚人可能会觉得这很奇怪，
on the stability and the sanity of Australian politics. Because basically, if your leaders are not intruding themselves on foreign consciousness, it generally implies that they're doing a good job. And I think that when you look at the evolution of Australia from its founding as a penal colony to the process where it becomes federated to now. It's an incredibly uplifting story, actually. I mean, it pains me as a cricket fan to admit this. And I remember the first time I went to Australia, I so so wanted to hate it and it was i loved it so much um and it annoys me to have to admit that australia is a much better run i seem so much happier well australians were saying a country than australian listeners may find this um bizarre because of
因为他们近期的政治历史是：他们大约每18个月换一次首相，而且正如我们稍后会看到的那样，他们都在互相背后捅刀子。但这是真的。我认为很多——如果你透过头条新闻来看，澳大利亚的故事，当然它确实有黑暗的篇章，但澳大利亚在20世纪和21世纪初的政治故事实际上，你知道，与法国、德国、英国、美国的历史相比，
course their recent political history they change prime minister about once every 18 months and they're all stabbing each other in the back as we will see when we get to the later stages. But it's true. I think a lot of the – if you look beneath the headlines, the story of Australia, of course it does have dark chapters, but the political story of Australia in the 20th century and early 21st is actually, you know, compared with the stories of, I don't know, France, Germany, Britain, the United States,
可以说是相当平静的，不是吗？我是说，这里有丑闻，有出错的事情，有各种问题，但它并不是——实际上，正如你所说，这是一个相当温和的故事。当然，并非完全温和，我知道，但相比之下。是的，所以首相们会丢掉裤子。其中一个会淹死，所以有各种各样的窘境和恶作剧，但它绝对没有达到大多数欧洲国家所经历的那种创伤水平。绝对是的，所以我们来聊聊
it's pretty untroubled, isn't it? I mean, there are scandals, there are things that go wrong, there are problems, but it's not – it's actually, as you say, it's a fairly sort of benevolent story. Of course, not completely benevolent, I know, but by comparison. Yeah, so prime ministers lose their trousers. One of them drowns um so there are various kind of scrapes and escapades but it's absolutely not on the level of the kind of traumas say that your most european countries went through exactly exactly so let's talk a bit
汤姆，在我们深入探讨之前——因为我们真的要重点关注战后、战时以及战后的首相，不是吗？但我们应该说点什么，因为澳大利亚政治对我们的许多英国听众来说简直是“不毛之地”（terra incognita）。我们应该谈谈政治文化，它的根源等等，不是吗？因为在某些方面它非常英国化。但在某些方面又不是。好吧，我所知道的那个早期首相其实是第一位首相。他叫埃德蒙·巴顿（Edmonton Barton）。
tom about um before we get into because we're really going to focus on the post-war on the wartime and then post-war prime ministers aren aren't we? But we should say something because Australian politics is terra incognita for so many of our British listeners. We should say something, shouldn't we, about the political culture, where it all comes from and so on. Because in some ways it's very British. And in some ways it isn't. Well, so the one prime minister, the early prime minister that I know about is actually the first prime minister. He's a guy called Edmund Barton. Yeah.
我之所以知道他，是因为他卷入了一场非常早期的板球丑闻。没错。所以在1879年，他担任了一场比赛的裁判，这场比赛因“悉尼大暴动”（Great Sydney Riot）而臭名昭著。当时在后来成为悉尼板球场（Sydney Cricket Ground）的场地上正在进行一场比赛，
And the reason that I know about him is because he was embroiled in a very early cricket scandal. Right. So in 1879, he umpired in a match that was notorious as the Great Sydney Riot. And a match was being played at the ground as the great sydney riot um and uh a match was being played at the ground that will is now the sydney cricket ground um and it was uh new south wales against an english touring team led by an aristocrat which just makes it perfect you know for the whole pommy aussie dynamic so lord harris yes uh and the um the english were you know this was long ago so back in those days the english did well in australia and they were they they were winning the match
这场比赛是新南威尔士队对阵由一位贵族率领的英国巡回球队，这简直完美契合了整个英国与澳大利亚的动态关系——哈里斯勋爵（Lord Harris），是的，而英国人——这发生在很久以前，所以在那时，英国人在澳大利亚表现不错，他们当时正赢得比赛。
and um one of the two umpires gave out the best australian batsman billy murdoch uh and there was a riot and there was a pitch invasion um and people wondered was this because they were trying to disrupt the match because um gambling syndicates were behind it? Or was it an expression of interstate rivalry because the umpire who'd given the New South Wales batsman out was from Victoria? Or what was going on? But Barton, as the other umpire, played a key role in diffusing the whole kind of bust-up.
其中两名裁判判罚了澳大利亚最优秀的击球手比利·默多克（Billy Murdoch）出局，于是爆发了骚乱，球迷冲入了球场。人们纷纷猜测：这是因为赌博集团在幕后操纵，企图破坏比赛？还是州际竞争的一种表现，因为判新南威尔士击球手出局的裁判来自维多利亚州？或者到底发生了什么？但巴顿作为另一名裁判，在平息整场冲突中发挥了关键作用。
So what did he do? Well, he essentially said that uh you know the unpassed ruling was final uh he reminded um everybody about that you know the essence of the you know the laws of cricket have to be uphold fair play all that kind of stuff but he did in a very sensitive way um and so it won him friends uh all around uh and i'm not saying that this is what enabled him to become first prime minister and the next thing you knew he was but i i you know i think i think it helped um and so he was he was he was very keen on australia becoming a country so he had this this phrase a nation for a continent a continent for a nation yes so so before that
那么他是怎么做的呢？嗯，他基本上表示，裁判的裁决是最终决定；他向所有人重申，板球规则的精髓必须得到维护，要公平竞争等等，但他以一种非常温和的方式表达了这一点。因此，这为他赢得了各方的好友谊。我并不是说这就是他能够成为第一任首相的原因，随之而来的……但我认为这确实起到了帮助。因此，他非常热衷于让澳大利亚成为一个国家，他曾提出过这样一个短语：“为大陆打造一个国家，为国家打造一个大陆”。是的，所以在此之前，
australia had been a series of colonies hadn't it new south wales victoria and so on um effectively administered by the colonial office yeah and and the the pressure for i mean we'll talk a little bit about some of the attributes of australian political culture but the pressure basically comes because they think they'll be stronger if they're fed if they're if they're united in one federation they say we have the same population now that the united states did when it became a nation um but also they're anxious aren't they about um china and yes that that threat actually was really interesting research in this how that as that perceived threat has run right through australian political history
澳大利亚曾是一系列殖民地，不是吗？新南威尔士、维多利亚等等，基本上由殖民地办公室管理。这种争取独立的压力——我们稍后会讨论澳大利亚政治文化的一些特点——压力基本上源于他们认为如果联合成一个联邦，他们会更强大。他们说：“我们现在拥有与美国建国时相同的人口规模。”但同时，他们也对中国感到担忧，这种威胁实际上贯穿了澳大利亚的政治历史。
from the late 19th century to the present this sort of sense of living next door to this giant which one day will awake so one of the one of the um reasons why federation is people in australia vote in favor of the federation is that um british strategists have warned that unless they do australia is likely to be invaded by china so even then there is kind of anxiety about this lurking you know this giant that's kind of i can't help thinking that's that was pretty rich given that that you know the boxer rebellion was happening in china and western powers were piling in well hypocrisy is of course the great british quality um so so that obviously is a theme and obviously the relationship with britain is a theme right yeah because that's so in in the in sort of the victorian era my image of australia was
从19世纪末一直延续到今天，这种生活在这个总有一天会醒来的庞然大物隔壁的意识一直存在。所以，澳大利亚人投票赞成联邦制的原因之一，就是英国战略家曾警告过他们，除非他们这样做，否则澳大利亚很可能会被中国入侵。所以即使在那个时候，对于这个潜伏着的、仿佛……我忍不住觉得，考虑到当时中国正在发生义和团运动，而西方列强正蜂拥而入，这种说法未免太奢侈了。虚伪当然是英国人的伟大特质，所以这显然是一个主题，而与英国的关系显然也是一个主题，对吧？因为在维多利亚时代，我对澳大利亚的印象
always you know it's basically there's mr pecksniff it's mr pecksniff no not mr pecksniff who's the fellow who's always running out of money uh mr mccorber mr mccorber there's mr mr mr mccorber there's magwitch. There's assorted other variations on that theme. So basically impecunious people, convicts and so on, people building new lives, sheep farmers. But it's very British. But of course, there is a cleavage right there in Australian political culture that's there
总而言之，你知道，基本上就是有皮克思尼夫先生，有皮克思尼夫先生，不，不是皮克思尼夫先生，谁是那个总是没钱的家伙，呃，麦考伯先生，麦考伯先生，有麦考伯先生，有麦格维奇。还有围绕这个主题的各种其他变体。所以基本上就是贫困潦倒的人、罪犯等等，开始新生活的人，养羊的农夫。但这非常英国化。但当然，澳大利亚政治文化中从一开始就存在一道裂痕，而且一直都在。
from the beginning to now. And it's between people who see themselves very much as the heirs of Britain and are more British than the British in some ways, and those who resent that. So particularly, originally, Irish. Irish Catholic convicts. So there's a religious dimension there as well,
从过去到现在。这道裂痕存在于那些自视甚在、将自己视为英国继承人、在某些方面甚至比英国人更英国化的人，以及那些对此感到愤慨的人之间。所以特别是最初的爱尔兰人。爱尔兰天主教罪犯。所以这里面也有一个宗教维度，
between Protestants and Catholics, between Anglos and Irish, basically between people who could claim descent from the prison warders and people who could claim descent from the convicts. That is the kind of tension that's always been there. It's fascinating because that, I think, in itself is very British because it mirrors what I think and what some historians, other historians think is one of the great sort of unspoken cleavages in British political life, which is between the people who the Church of England, people whose ancestors might have been in the Church of England, and those who are dissenters or Catholics or whatever, who'd be more likely to be drawn to non-Tory parties. And I think you can definitely see elements of that culturally in Australian politics. Yeah, absolutely. Yes. I mean, because I think the liberal and Labour divide in Australia does map quite closely onto the Tory-Labour divide here in Britain.
在新教徒和天主教徒之间，在盎格鲁人和爱尔兰人之间，基本上是在那些能声称自己是狱卒后代的人，和那些能声称自己是罪犯后代的人之间。这种紧张关系一直都存在。这很迷人，因为我认为这本身就非常英国化，因为它反映了我认为以及其他一些历史学家认为英国政治生活中一个巨大的、未曾明说的裂痕，也就是圣公会成员——祖先可能属于圣公会的人——与异见人士、天主教徒或其他什么人之间的裂痕，后者更有可能被非保守党阵营吸引。我认为你在澳大利亚政治的文化中绝对能看到这方面的元素。是的，绝对是的。是的。我的意思是，因为我认为澳大利亚的自由党和工党的分裂，与英国的保守党和工党的分裂非常吻合。
Yeah. And once you start looking at their biographies and what kind of schools they went to, what kind of household they were raised in, basically, where they went to church of Australian prime ministers, you can often predict what party they'll be in. Not always, though, as we'll find out. No, not always. But the other thing that I know, because I've got your notes in front of me, Tom, because of your extraordinary Australian enthusiasm,
是的。一旦你开始研究他们的传记，他们上过什么学校，他们在什么样的家庭中长大，基本上他们去过澳大利亚总理的哪个教堂，你往往就能预测他们会加入哪个党派。不过也不是总是如此，正如我们将要发现的那样。不，不总是这样。但另一件事我知道，因为我手里拿着你的笔记，汤姆，因为你对澳大利亚有着非同寻常的热情，
you've produced these colossal notes. Mateship. So the masculinity of Australian politics. That's really interesting, isn't it? So, yes. So in the wake of the ball tampering scandal that afflicted the Australian cricket team a few years ago. Who was the fellow who cried?
你写了这些庞大的笔记。兄弟情谊（Mateship）。也就是澳大利亚政治的男子气概。这真的很有趣，不是吗？所以，是的。在几年前困扰澳大利亚板球队的球场做手脚丑闻之后。那个哭了的家伙是谁？
Steve Smith. Yes. The Australian captain when he resigned. There was a kind of you know we need new brooms we're going to set things up and the the phrase that um the australian cricket team promoted was elite mateship which that's kind of the rubbish that you'd come out with well we obviously everybody in our cricket team immediately said we've got to have elite mateship but that idea of mateship it's been argued by cultural historians of australia is reflective of the fact that australia to begin with was a very tough environment particularly if you're a convict or you're on the chain gang or if you're going out if you're a gold prospector or whatever it was tough and so you you needed to depend on one another. And so therefore, there is a much more egalitarian strain within Australian societal relationships and working environment than you would get, say, in Britain.
史蒂夫·史密斯。是的。当时辞职的澳大利亚队长。当时有一种“你知道我们需要新扫帚，我们要整顿一切”的氛围，呃，澳大利亚板球队推广的词是精英兄弟情谊，这就有点像你会说出来的垃圾话，我们板球队的每个人显然立刻都说我们必须拥有精英兄弟情谊，但这种兄弟情谊的思想，正如澳大利亚的文化历史学家所争论的那样，反映了这样一个事实：澳大利亚一开始是一个非常艰难的环境，特别是如果你是个罪犯，或者你在苦役犯帮里，或者如果你出去，如果你是一个黄金勘探者或其他什么，总之很艰难，所以你需要彼此依靠。因此，与英国相比，澳大利亚社会关系和工作环境中存在着一种更加平等的基调。
Yeah, I think that's definitely true, isn't it? I mean, there's also that sense of throwing off the hierarchies and the sort of stuffiness of the old world isn't yeah and so australia is um you know even in um even when hillar belloc is writing that kind of sneery poem about yeah the lord go off to go and use south world it's already by even by today's standards strikingly progressive so votes for women um i brought in 1902 and and some states had had that you know even before that um you've got free and compulsory education for all children is an idea that is very very firmly held so that in victoria that dates back to 1872 um you've got old age pensions um invalidity pensions brought in in 1908 minimum wage brought in in 1907 um and so all of this, I think, combines to give Australia
是的，我想这绝对是真的，不是吗？我的意思是，也有一种摆脱旧世界的等级制度和迂腐气息的感觉，是的，所以澳大利亚是，你知道，甚至在，甚至当希莱尔·贝洛克写那种讽刺性的诗，关于“噢，领主们去索思沃德”时，按今天的标准来看，它已经是非常进步的了；所以妇女选举权，呃，在1902年引入，有些州甚至在那之前就有了，呃，你为所有儿童提供免费和义务教育，这是一个非常坚定持有的理念，所以在维多利亚州，这可以追溯到1872年，呃，你有了老年养老金，呃，1908年引入的残疾养老金，1907年引入的最低工资，所以所有这些，我认为，结合起来赋予了澳大利亚
an incredibly high standard of living, which, of course, in turn makes it appealing to people in Britain, perhaps. Yeah. You know, Tom, if there was such a thing as the Australian Historical Tourist Board, they could not find a more enthusiastic advocate. Well, except that there are downsides to this tradition of mateship yeah one of which is that it's quite sexist yeah so there's quite a sexist strain i think you know you know not to say that there wasn't in britain well we should be we will be coming to the the
令人难以置信的高生活水平，这当然反过来又对英国人很有吸引力，也许吧。是的。你知道，汤姆，如果有什么澳大利亚历史旅游局的话，他们绝对找不到比这更热情的倡导者了。好吧，除了这种兄弟情谊的传统也有阴暗面之外，是的，其中之一就是它相当大男子主义，是的，所以我觉得里面有一种相当性别歧视的倾向，你知道，并不是说英国没有——嗯，我们应该，我们会讲到朱莉娅·吉拉德的
prime premiership of julia gillard yes later in the in the podcast won't we um and also i think it's led to a pretty overtly racist tradition for much of the 20th century, which where Australian, both on Labour as well as on the right, have been absolutely upfront about saying that Australia should be white. So the white only policy. Well, it's a white Australia policy, wasn't it? Wasn't that what they called it? Yeah. Yeah. And so that's their right pretty much from the beginning. So in 1981, which is the year of federation, you have the Immigration Restriction Act act and then this other one this quarantine act which basically so you come in you're cut you're coming from a country outside europe and you have to if if the if the the immigration official says you've got you know give me 50 words in a european language and the immigration official can choose
总理任期，对吧，在播客的后面，我们会讲到的，对吧？呃，而且我也认为，在20世纪的大部分时间里，它导致了一种相当公开的种族主义传统，在这种传统中，澳大利亚人，无论是工党还是右翼，都毫不掩饰地公开表示澳大利亚应该是一个白人的国家。所以也就是纯白政策。嗯，这就是白澳政策，不是吗？他们不是这么叫的吗？是的。是的。所以这基本上从一开始就是他们的权利。所以在1901年，也就是联邦成立的那一年，你有了《移民限制法》，然后还有另一个，这个《检疫法》，基本上就是——你进来，你从欧洲以外的国家来，如果——如果移民官员说，给你50个欧洲语言的单词，而且移民官员可以挑选
the european language that's ridiculous it's laughable so you know you get people from malaya or something being asked to give 50 words in italian or portuguese portuguese or something but any 50 what can they can the officer choose the 50 words i think so i think so i mean maybe australian listeners could clarify if i've got that wrong but i think that's the case and so effectively it serves as a you know way of keeping non-europeans out um and also of course it's expressive of this sense that um that asia in particular is pestiferous that it's a breeding ground for disease and that's quite again quite a strong tradition that runs throughout certainly the first half of the 20th century in australia and into the the post-war years so um so that's that's perhaps an aspect
欧洲语言，这太荒谬了，简直滑稽，所以你知道，你会看到来自马来亚或其他地方的人被要求说出50个意大利语或葡萄牙语或类似语言的单词，但是任意50个，官员可以挑选这50个词吗？我想是的，我想是的，我的意思是，也许澳大利亚听众可以澄清一下，如果我弄错了的话，但我认为情况确实如此，所以它实际上起到了一种把非欧洲人挡在门外的作用，呃，当然这也表达了一种感觉，即特别是亚洲是瘟疫横行的，它是疾病滋生的温床，这同样是贯穿整个20世纪前半叶以及战后岁月的一项相当强烈的传统，所以——所以这也许是一个
that is is less noble and then of course um there is the relationship of the the white settlers with the indigenous people of australia yeah the aborigines as many people don't so that also is you know how white australia relates to them um whether they you know policies that are introduced to try and integrate aborigines into white society often attempts to do that generate further injustices how people that how the australian government and society then respond to that so that's another theme so So I think these are all... Yeah. Well, obviously the confiscation of children is the most famous and controversial example, isn't it? So these themes are all running through,
不那么高尚的方面，然后当然，呃，还有白人定居者与澳大利亚原住民的关系，是的，也就是许多人所说的土著人，所以这也是，你知道的，白澳如何对待他们，无论是他们实施的试图将土著人融入白人社会的政策，往往这种尝试又会产生新的不公，以及澳大利亚政府和社会的反应如何，所以这是另一个主题。所以我觉得这些都是……是的。好吧，显而易见，没收儿童是最著名、最具争议的例子，不是吗？所以这些主题都贯穿其中，
the Irish versus English, egalitarianism, the mateship, the racism, all of this sort of stuff. So, Tom, let's fast forward now. 1901 Federation, the event that many people will immediately think of as one of the building blocks of modern Australian, sort of a distinctive Australian identity, which is World War I and Gallipoli in particular. So where do you think all that fits in? Well, so Gallipoli is, you know, it's enshrined in Australian folklore as lions led by donkeys. And in this case, the don are british and the lions are
爱尔兰人对英国人、平等主义、兄弟情谊、种族主义，诸如此类。所以，汤姆，让我们现在快进。1901年联邦成立，许多人会立刻将其视为现代澳大利亚建国基石之一的事件，即一种独特的澳大利亚身份，也就是第一次世界大战，特别是加里波利之战。所以你认为这一切是怎么契合的呢？嗯，所以加里波利，你知道，它在澳大利亚民间传说中被奉为“驴子率领的狮子”。在这个案例中，驴子是英国人，而狮子是
australian you know that's very unfair actually because more british and irish died at gallipoli than australians i'm saying that that is the yeah that's the sense that you have in australia so steve war the most fearsome of all uh recent australian cricket captains steve war you're literally well w-a-u-g-a i know his name i know steve war is i just i thought you were going to mention some you know top historian at the university of melbourne steve war when he brought the australian team over would take them to gallipoli before coming to england to to steal them for the fight stick it to the poms um so so that's that's a kind of downside but i think it's important to say that the first world war did also cement Anglo-Australian relations.
澳大利亚人，你知道，这其实很不公平，因为在加里波利阵亡的英国人和爱尔兰人比澳大利亚人还要多。我是说，这就是——是的，这就是你在澳大利亚的感觉。所以史蒂夫·沃，所有近期澳大利亚板球队长中最令人畏惧的史蒂夫·沃，你字面意思上的，嗯，W-A-U-G-H，我知道他的名字，我知道史蒂夫·沃是谁，我只是以为你要提到墨尔本大学的什么顶级历史学家。史蒂夫·沃在带澳大利亚队过来时，会在来英格兰之前先带他们去加里波利，以此来激发他们战斗的意志，给英国人（Poms）好看……所以——所以这算是一个阴暗面，但我认为必须指出的是，第一次世界大战确实也巩固了英澳关系。
There was a feeling that it had been a shared sacrifice. So Billy Hughes, who was the Lloyd George of Australia, prime minister during the First World War, the tendency to regard Britain with suspicion or the tendency to see that we're kind of kin. Yes. So you've got that. And then, of course, the other famous episode is Bodyline. Oh, yeah. We talked about that in a previous podcast, didn't we? But for people who don't remember, that's the cricket tour in, what is it, 1930? You'll know, Tom. Three, isn't it? So Douglas Jardine is the captain.
有一种感觉，认为这是一场共同的牺牲。所以比利·休斯，被称为澳大利亚劳合·乔治的人，是一战期间的首相，他倾向于对英国抱有怀疑，或者倾向于认为我们是一家人。是的。所以你有这个。然后，当然，另一个著名的事件是“身体线”（Bodyline）战术。哦，是的。我们在之前的播客里谈过这个，对吧？但对于不记得的人来说，那是板球巡回赛，在什么时候，1930年？你会知道的，汤姆。三年的，对吧？所以道格拉斯·查丁是队长。
Larwood is the bowler. They're seen as dreadful British, destroying sporting play and all this kind of thing by bowling too hard at these poor, wilting Australian batsmen. That's about right, isn't it, Tom? That's a very fair description of them. That's a very fair description. But also the other thing about it, of course that when um when the australians complain to
劳伍德是投球手。他们被那些差劲的英国人视为摧毁了体育精神以及所有这些东西，因为他们对这些可怜、萎靡不振的澳大利亚击球手投球太猛了。差不多就是这样吧，汤姆？这真是一个非常公正的描述。这真是一个非常公正的描述。但除此之外的另一件事是，当然，当呃——当澳大利亚人向
to the english management um about what's going on namely that there's kind of physical intimidation with the cricket ball going on on the cricket pitch um they're doing so in very english terms they're saying you know this isn't cricket this is not this is not how you play the game so again there is that kind of tension and that of course then takes us into the second world war which is really kind of the great dividing line and it is the great dividing line isn't it so let's start with the prime minister who um who is most associated i suppose with the the second world war certainly the beginning of the second world war and that is robert gordon menzies so he's from rural vict, isn't he? He's obsessed with cricket. Surprise, surprise.
英国管理层投诉发生了什么事时，也就是板球场上正发生着用板球进行身体恐吓的事，他们是用非常英国化的方式来表达的，他们说，你知道，这不符合板球精神，这可不是你们玩游戏的方式。所以这里再次存在那种紧张关系，而这当然又把我们带入了第二次世界大战，这真的是一条巨大的分水岭，它确实是一条巨大的分水岭，对吧？所以让我们从这位首相开始，呃——他最常被与第二次世界大战联系在一起，当然是二战的初期，那就是罗伯特·戈登·梅恩兹（Robert Gordon Menzies）；所以他来自维多利亚州的乡村，对吧？他痴迷于板球。毫不奇怪。
Am I right in thinking I see from the notes he's the first prime minister to have two Australian parents? So in other words, native-born Australians rather than immigrants. But he's very British, isn't he? He loves the royal family and British traditions. British to the bootstraps was his famous self-description. And his name, interestingly, so it's obviously a Scottish surname, which Scots will tell you is pronounced Mingus. And he would have told you that himself, I think, wouldn't he? Yes, he did. And so one of his nicknames was Ming, Ming the Merciless.
我没记错的话，从笔记上看他是第一位父母双方都是澳大利亚人的总理？换句话说，是本土出生的澳大利亚人，而不是移民。但他非常英国化，不是吗？他热爱王室和英国传统。“至死不渝的英国人”（British to the bootstraps）是他著名的自我评价。而且有趣的是，他的名字，显然是一个苏格兰姓氏，苏格兰人会告诉你它的发音是明格斯（Mingus）。我想他自己也会这么告诉你，对吧？是的，他确实这么说过。所以他的外号之一就是明格（Ming），无情者明格。
Right. But everybody, because I watched a newsreel of him arriving in, a Pathé newsreel of him making one of his trips to Britain during the Second World War. And he's very clearly Menzies. Yes, so nobody picked up on that. But it was an affectation that he would have liked to see develop. But there are two things about him that are notable as a young man, Tom. One of them, very disappointing for you, although he liked cricket,
对的。但是每个人——因为我看过一段关于他抵达的百代（Pathé）新闻短片，记录了他在二战期间去英国的其中一次旅行。他非常明显就是明恩斯（Menzies）。是的，所以没有人注意到那个发音。但他本来希望看到这种发音习惯发展起来。但是关于他，有两件值得注意的事，汤姆，当他还是个年轻人时。其中一件，对你来说非常令人失望，尽管他喜欢板球，
he was very bad at sport himself. Well, a lot of fellow feeling there. So there's that. But then more importantly, his middle name, he is named after very much a friend of the rest of his history, General Gordon. Is he really named after General Gordon or is it just a coincidence? Yeah, he is.
他自己体育非常糟糕。嗯，这倒有很多同感。所以有这个。但更重要的是，他的中间名，他是以他一生历史中的好友戈登将军（General Gordon）的名字命名的。他真的是以戈登将军的名字命名的，还是只是巧合？是的，他确实是。
Are we just making that up? No, he really was. Wow, that's splendid. He's a big fan of Aussie rules, which is obviously, because that's in Victoria, isn't it? Aussie rules, that's Melbourne. Yeah. Anyway, so he goes into the,
我们不是在瞎编吧？不，他真的是。哇，太棒了。他是澳式橄榄球（Aussie rules）的超级粉丝，这显然是因为那是在维多利亚州，对吧？澳式橄榄球，那是墨尔本的。无论如何，所以他进入了，
he becomes a politician in the United Australia party, which is the ancestor of the liberal party. And he, he, he just as well for him. He resigned just before the second world war in protest at the lack of defense spending, which obviously is good for him.
他成了联合澳大利亚党（United Australia Party）的一名政治家，这是自由党的祖先。而他，他，他在二战爆发前夕辞职，以抗议缺乏国防开支，这对他来说显然是件好事。
It means he's a bit of Anthony Eden because he can then look like, you know, sort of, although he's, he is hamstrung as a war leader because he had not volunteered for overseas service in the First World War. That's right. And he said, people throw mud at me everywhere I go.
这意味着他有点像安东尼·伊登（Anthony Eden），因为他随后可以看起来像，你知道的，尽管他在作为一个战时领导人时受到了束缚，因为他在第一次世界大战中没有志愿参加海外服役。没错。他说，我走到哪里，人们都向我泼污水。
I'm trotting through a trench of mud, he said, or something, words to that effect. A slightly ill-chosen image, you might think. Yeah, not the most diplomatic. But that was because he was one of three brothers and the other two had gone. Yes, that's right. So he got the long straw, I guess, on that.
我正踩着一地污泥前行，他说，或者类似的话。你可能会觉得这是一个稍微不太恰当的比喻。是的，不是最外交辞令的。但那是因为他是三兄弟之一，另外两个都去了。是的，没错。所以我想他抽到了比较长的干草签（意指抽到了好签）。
Yeah, he did. So he becomes prime minister towards the end of 1939. And he's very popular in Britain, isn't he? At one point, people are talking about him as a replacement for Churchill. Well, I think Menzies is himself. Yeah. I think very implausibly, very implausibly.
是的，他确实如此。所以他在1939年底成为总理。他在英国非常受欢迎，对吧？有一段时间，人们甚至在谈论他可以取代丘吉尔。嗯，我想梅恩兹自己也是这么想的。是的。我认为非常不切实际，非常不切实际。
Yeah. There were always sort of claims that, Oh, some Commonwealth prime minister, because I think people sort of fantasize that Commonwealth prime minister would be untouched by the partisanship of the house of commerce. Smuts was also often mentioned. Smuts,
是的。总是有种说法，哦，某个英联邦总理——因为我认为人们有点幻想英联邦总理不会受到下议院党派之争的影响。史末资（Smuts）也经常被提及。史末资，
exactly. But yeah, he throws Australia wholeheartedly into the Second World War, doesn't he? And then for two years, so just before Pearl Harbor, he's kicked out. Well, but I think what's interesting is, and again, this is a theme that runs particularly through the narrative of the Second World War, is that one of the reasons he goes to Britain is not just to maybe become Prime Minister of Britain, but also more germinely to try and ensure that the British High Command don't forget the Pacific Theatre, because they're twitchy about that.
没错。但是，是的，他全身心地把澳大利亚投入到第二次世界大战中，不是吗？然后在两年里——就在珍珠港事件发生前不久，他被赶下台了。不过，我认为有趣的是，而且这也是一条贯穿二战叙事的特殊主线，他去英国的一个原因不仅仅是为了也许能当上英国首相，而且更真诚地是为了试图确保英国最高指挥部不会忘记太平洋战区，因为他们对此感到坐立不安。
About Japan, obviously. About Japan. Kind of very, very kind of sensitive to it. So I think that, but I think there is also a kind of crucial thing that Menzies is very into the idea of the Anglosphere and the Commonwealth of English-speaking nations and all that kind of crucial thing that uh menzies is very into the idea of the anglosphere and the commonwealth of english-speaking nations and all that kind of stuff and there's a famous account of him going to ottawa um and uh he's he's staying with the um uh with the governor general there and he stays up late showing him his travel snaps oh that's nice the governor general's desperate to go to bed that's nice that's like uh well churchill behave very badly at the at the same time with Roosevelt staying up late drinking his brandy and talking about great battles of history.
显然是对日本。对日本。对这件事相当相当敏感。所以我想，但我也认为有一个至关重要的事，那就是梅恩兹非常热衷于盎格鲁圈（Anglosphere）以及英语国家英联邦等诸如此类的理念，而梅恩兹非常热衷于盎格鲁圈和英语国家英联邦等诸如此类的事情，这里有一个著名的记载，说他去了渥太华，呃，他跟那里的总督住在一起，他熬夜向总督展示他的旅行快照。哦，这真好，总督急着想睡觉。这真好，这就像——嗯，丘吉尔在同一时期跟罗斯福在一起时的糟糕表现一样，熬夜喝白兰地，谈论历史上的伟大战役。
So maybe Menzies and Churchill should just cut out the middleman and stay up late together. Yeah, maybe they should have done. Anyway, but he's obviously away for quite a while, I mean, over a year. And by the time he gets back to Australia, essentially, you know, things have been happening there and he gets politically assassinated. He does, doesn't he? He wants to go again. He wants to go on another trip. He wants to go back, I think, and try and become prime. The story is, again, he wants to go back to become prime minister of Britain.
所以也许梅恩兹和丘吉尔应该直接省去中间人，一起熬夜得了。是的，也许他们当时应该这么做。无论如何，但他显然离开了一段时间，我的意思是，超过一年。当他回到澳大利亚时，基本上，你知道，那里已经发生了诸多事情，他在政治上被暗杀了。确实如此，不是吗？他还想再去。他还想再去旅行一次。我想他想回去，试图成为首相。故事又是这样的，他想回去当英国首相。
And he needs the permission of Labour to do that. He won't countenance going into coalition with Labour. And so this is what ends up bringing him down. Yeah. As you say, I've been done. I'll lie down and bleed a while. Now, actually, I could have done that in an Australian accent, but it would have been wrong because I've listened to him talking.
而他需要工党的许可才能做到这一点。他不赞成与工党组建联合政府。所以这最终导致了他的下台。是的。正如你所说，我已经被打倒了，我要躺下来流一会儿血。其实，我本来可以用澳大利亚口音说这句话的，但那样就不对了，因为我听过他说话。
And he's not very Australian in his – he's quite British. To the bootstraps. In his speech, as actually interestingly fdr was so if you listen to fdr's addresses he's much less american and more british i mean he was a very patrician figure in his intonation and it's interesting that australians at this point don't sound like they don't sound like paul hogan well so i think men's it's definitely not definitely not so he he he they get rid of him and Arthur Fadden. So Australia specializes in these interim caretaker prime ministers, doesn't it?
而且他在他的口音中并不是很澳大利亚——他相当英国化。至死不渝。在他的演讲中，实际上有趣的是，FDR也是如此，所以如果你听FDR的演讲，他少了很多美国味，更多英国味——我的意思是，他在语调上是一个非常贵族气派的人物，有趣的是，当时的澳大利亚人听起来并不像——他们听起来不像保罗·霍根（Paul Hogan）。嗯，所以我觉得梅恩兹绝对不是，绝对不是。所以他——他们把他赶下台了，换上了亚瑟·法登（Arthur Fadden）。所以澳大利亚盛产这种过渡性质的看守总理，不是吗？
Yeah. Who are almost always from the country party. No, I think Arthur Fadden is the only prime minister from the country party. Aren't they? The others are from small parties often, aren't they? No, I think they're all. Anyway, we'll get into them. So Arthur Fadden,
是的。他们几乎总是来自乡村党。不，我认为亚瑟·法登是乡村党唯一的首相。不是吗？其他人通常来自小党派，对吧？不，我想他们都是。总之，我们会研究他们。所以亚瑟·法登，
interesting fact about him is he was once part of a blackface minstrel troupe. Yeah. So he's the Justin Trudeau. He's the Justin Trudeau of Australian politics. Oh, it's so simple. I think we should take a break
关于他一个有趣的事实是，他曾是一个滑稽黑人妆扮歌舞剧团的成员。是的。所以他是澳大利亚政坛的贾斯廷·特鲁多。他是澳大利亚政坛的贾斯廷·特鲁多。哦，这太简单了。我想我们应该休息一下
at this point. And when we come back, we should look at the great Australian war leader. Tom, we've done one. We've done one prime minister in all this time. It's shocking. That's fine. It's fine. Even by our standards. So let's come back. We've done one. We've done one prime minister in all this time. That's fine.
在这个时候。当我们回来时，我们应该看看伟大的澳大利亚战时领袖。汤姆，我们已经讲了一个。在这么长的时间里我们只讲了一位首相。这太令人震惊了。没关系。没关系。甚至以我们的标准来看也是如此。所以我们回来吧。我们讲了一个。在这么长的时间里我们只讲了一位首相。没关系。
That's fine. It's fine. Even by our standards. So let's come back. We'll look at the great Australian war leader, John Curtin. I'm Marina Hyde.
没关系。没关系。甚至以我们的标准来看也是如此。所以我们回来吧。我们将探讨伟大的澳大利亚战时领袖约翰·柯丁。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的来源。在我们的问答环节，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about Australia's titanic political leaders. And Tom, we're about to get into a man who you just described
我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、独家番外节目并优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史至上》。我们正在讨论澳大利亚伟大的政治领袖。汤姆，我们即将介绍一位你刚刚形容为
as Australia's great war leader, John Curtin. And I'm going to guess that most of our British listeners will never have heard of John Curtin, which is a very good example, actually, of the way that Australian politics is occluded from the British imagination. As you say, John Curtin is a massive figure in australian history um and in civilization six if anyone's played that he's the leader of australia isn't yeah civilization he's the
澳大利亚伟大战时领袖的人物——约翰·柯丁。我猜我们的大多数英国听众可能从未听说过约翰·柯丁，这其实是一个很好的例子，说明了澳大利亚政治是如何被英国人的想象力所忽视的。正如你所说，约翰·柯丁是澳大利亚历史上的一个庞大人物，嗯，在《文明6》里，如果有人玩过的话，他是澳大利亚的领袖，没错，《文明》里他是
face of australia yeah against genghis khan or augustus caesar well i mean yeah but that speaks well of australia that they don't have a blood-soaked dictator. It absolutely does. Yes. And that's, yeah, absolutely does. So he's Labour. Yes. And so therefore, almost inevitably, his parents are from Ireland. Yeah, from Cork.
澳大利亚的代表人物，对吧，对抗成吉思汗或屋大维。嗯，我是说，是的，但这也说明澳大利亚很好，因为他们没有一个血腥的独裁者。完全是这样。是的。那是，是的，绝对是。所以他是工党的。是的。因此，几乎不可避免地，他的父母来自爱尔兰。是的，来自科克。
And he's Catholic. Yeah. So. So. Very well my in-laws. Yeah. And he's cross-eyed, which wouldn't. Not that they've got anything against
而且他是斗鸡眼，这不会——倒不是说他们对……有什么意见
cross-eyed people but it's just they wouldn't be especially impressed i think because didn't that didn't that sort of play a part in his i don't know self-image or something yeah i think he was very self-conscious about it yes uh but tom i see in your notes you've written the dread words solid batsman and he was absolutely obsessive on uh cricket stats yeah which i think you know if you're kind of having to work out um logistics it's probably good training it's interesting how cricket plays such a massive part in australian life compared within britain doesn't it you must it's the only national sport in australia you must look on this with a real sense of yearning because i do this would not be true of ted heath or margaret thatcher no i mean john major admittedly yes but but not um but but not most of them
斜视的人，不过只是他们不会觉得特别印象深刻，我想，因为这难道不是在他的——我不知道——自我形象中起了一定作用吗？是的，我觉得他对此非常在意。是的，不过汤姆，我看到在你的笔记里写着“可靠的得分手”这几个可怕的词，而且他对板球统计数据有着绝对的执念。是的，我想如果你不得不处理某些后勤工作的话，这或许是个很好的训练。板球在澳大利亚生活中占据如此巨大的比重，与英国相比，这真是有趣，不是吗？你一定用一种真正的渴望来看待这一点，因为我确实如此。这在特德·希思或玛格丽特·撒切尔身上可不成立，不，我是说约翰·梅杰固然是的，但并非——并非绝大多数人。
but most of these guys are absolutely obsessed with cricket i think well it's not just cricket also i mean all kinds of sport i think sport has a really central role in Australia. Yeah. Right. Let's talk about John Curtin. So he's a trade unionist. And actually, he's very much on the left of the union movement as a young man, isn't he? He's practically a Marxist. Pretty much a Marxist as a young man. Yeah. And he's anti-imperial. He's anti-war. So very much from that kind of tradition um australian marxist tradition that's not one that you often hear about but it is you know so australia before say the um before the russian revolution is probably the most left-wing country well that's what's so interesting australia this is precisely the thing though you don't hear a lot about the Australian Marxist tradition, but Australia, its political culture, which we would perceive, I think,
但这些家伙大都对板球有着绝对的执念，我觉得。嗯，不仅仅是板球，还有各种各样的运动，我觉得体育在澳大利亚占据着非常核心的地位。是的。没错。我们来谈谈约翰·柯廷（John Curtin）。他是一名工会会员。实际上，他年轻时非常倾向于工会运动的左翼，对吧？他简直是个马克思主义者。年轻时几乎就是个马克思主义者。是的。而且他反帝国主义。他反战。因此，他非常符合那种传统——澳大利亚的马克思主义传统。这不是那种你经常听说的传统，但它确实存在。所以澳大利亚在比如说——在俄国革命之前，可能是最左翼的国家。嗯，这就是最有趣的地方。澳大利亚，这正是关键所在，虽然你不太常听到澳大利亚的马克思主义传统，但澳大利亚的政治文化——我们在局外人看来，
as outsiders, as being very macho and all about barbecues and stuff, is actually clearly, to my mind, more left-wing than France's political culture, which is perceived in Britain as much more left-wing. But it's a masculine left-wing culture. Yeah, well, it is. It is. As we will explore. So anyway, he voted against conscription in World War I, hadn't he?
会觉得非常大男子主义，整天都是烧烤什么的——实际上在我看来，明显比法国的政治文化更左翼，而法国在英国人看来要左翼得多。但那是一种带有男子气概的左翼文化。是的，没错。确实如此。正如我们将要探讨的那样。无论如何，他在第一次世界大战中投票反对征兵，对吧？
He'd moved to Perth in Western Australia, and he'd become more moderate in the interwar years, John Curtin. And he becomes – so he's the prime minister who basically has to deal with Pearl Harbor. Yeah. And with the effects of that. and uh he becomes so he's the prime minister who basically has to deal with pearl harbor yeah and with the and with the effects of that and with the the colossal kind of japanese um onslaught through southeast asia yeah and he makes this absolutely landmark declaration at the end of december 1941 that really probably you could argue is one of the two or three great turning points in australian australia's entire history um without any inhibitions of any kind i make it
他曾搬到西澳大利亚州的珀斯，在两次世界大战之间变得更加温和了，约翰·柯廷。他成为了——所以他是基本上必须应对珍珠港事件的首相。是的。以及由此带来的影响。呃，他成为了——所以他是基本上必须应对珍珠港事件的首相。是的，以及由此带来的影响，以及日本通过东南亚发起的排山倒海般的猛烈进攻。是的，他在1941年12月底发表了这篇极具里程碑意义的声明，这可能可以说是澳大利亚整个历史上两三个伟大转折点之一。毫无任何形式的心理负担，我明确
quite clear that australia looks to america free of any pangs as to our traditional links or kinship with the united kingdom so i mean you know it's right there explicit we're now looking to the americans and yeah and that's partly because he thinks the British have sold them out. Yes. I think he quite correctly recognises that for Britain, the focus is on defending the British Isles, British homeland. And that therefore, say, Singapore is not as strongly defended as it might be uh which is why the fall of singapore which follows in the wake of pearl harbour is is seen as such a you know it's so
表态，澳大利亚将目光投向美国，彻底抛开了我们与英国的传统纽带或血缘关系的任何纠结。所以我的意思是，这就在那里，非常明确：我们现在指望美国人了。是的，部分原因是他认为英国人出卖了他们。是的。我认为他非常正确地认识到，对英国而言，重心在于保卫不列颠群岛、英国本土。因此，比如说，新加坡的防御可能没有那么牢固——这就是为什么紧随珍珠港事件之后新加坡的陷落，被视为如此（你知道的）——
calamitous for anglo-australian relations because it's it's a humiliation for britain but it's kind of you know it's it's an existential crisis for australians and so the mud flinging over that is is pretty you know it's pretty bad so the because that's what gallipoli they sort of say the british officers are dead effectless wasters who are yeah they're incompetent and useless gin and tonics yeah with their stupid straggly mustaches and their baggy short yes exactly that they're useless and the british have an absolutely an absolutely splendidly scathing line about the Australians, I have to say. The Australians were known as daffodils, beautiful to look at,
对英澳关系来说简直是一场灾难，因为这不仅是对英国的羞辱，对澳大利亚人来说更是一场生存危机。因此，围绕这件事的互相指责相当（你知道的）相当糟糕。因为这就是加里波利事件的翻版，他们会说英国军官都是毫无用处的废物，只会——是的，他们无能且毫无用处，喝着金汤尼——是的，留着愚蠢稀疏的胡子和宽松的短裤——是的，绝对如此，他们一无是处。不过对于澳大利亚人，英国人倒有一句极其尖刻犀利的话，我必须得说。澳大利亚人曾被称为“水仙花”：看着光鲜亮丽，
but yellow all through. Yeah, I mean, that's not helpful, is it? No, it's not very helpful for Anglo-Australian. No. No. And also what's not helpful is that in the face of this disaster, Churchill pulls British troops and the Navy back to the two key kind of blocks of the empire, India and Australia.
内里却懦弱不堪。是的，我是说，这可帮不上什么忙，对吧？不，这对英澳关系没有什么帮助。不，没有。而且同样无济于事的是，面对这场灾难，丘吉尔将英国军队和海军撤回到了帝国的两个核心板块——印度和澳大利亚。
But again, he makes it perfectly clear that India is more important than Australia. Yeah, Australia is not happy, unsurprisingly, which is why they turned to the United States and why I think you get from this point onwards. I mean, this is the sort of the thread that leads all the way through to Paul Keating in the 1990s because he actually refers to this doesn't he he does yes yeah um yeah so i mean it's still it's still a kind of itch to to scratch in the 1990s um and it's it's you know it becomes all the more kind of sensitive
但同样，他把话说得很明白：印度比澳大利亚更重要。是的，澳大利亚很不高兴，这并不令人意外，这也是他们转向美国的原因，也是我认为从这一刻开始延续下来的原因。我的意思是，这就是一直延续到20世纪90年代保罗·基廷（Paul Keating）的那条线索，因为他实际上提到了这一点，不是吗？他确实提到了。是的。是的，所以我的意思是，这在20世纪90年代仍然是一个需要去挠的痒痒，而且它变得——变得愈发敏感，
because australia actually comes under attack so the japanese bombed darwin yeah um in i think it's kind of early 1942 and then notoriously there's a japanese submarine makes its way into sydney harbour and sinks a couple of ships so australians feel really really vulnerable about this yeah um and you can see why they absolutely just go okay wait you think britain's useless let's let's sign up to America. Although, interestingly, John Curtin himself never, I mean, he never sort of disavows the link with Britain because he says at one point about the white Australia policy that, you know, we are the descendants of people who came here
因为澳大利亚确实遭到了袭击。所以日本人轰炸了达尔文——是的——大约在1942年初，随后臭名昭著的是，一艘日本潜艇驶入悉尼港并击沉了几艘船。因此澳大利亚人对此感到非常非常脆弱。是的，你可以理解为什么他们彻底破罐子破摔，心想：“好吧，既然你觉得英国没用，那我们就跟美国结盟吧。”不过有趣的是，约翰·柯廷本人从未——我是说，他从未公开否认与英国的联系，因为他在谈到“白澳政策”时曾表示，我们是来到这里的人的后代，
to, quote, to establish in the South Seas an outpost of the British race. And he's absolutely unapologetic about that. Yeah, I mean, I don't think there's a contradiction there. sees an outpost of the british race and he's absolutely unapologetic about the yeah i mean i don't think there's a contradiction there i i i think he feels that britain in a way has betrayed a trust or perhaps is simply impotent to uphold that trust whereas whereas america is the face of the future you know vast numbers of course of conscripts so this is also an issue is that curtain is uh youin had originally made his name voting against conscription. And I think he increasingly comes to feel that as Australia
（引用原话）“在南海建立一个英国种目前哨站”的人。对此，他 absolutamente 毫无歉意。是的，我是说，我不认为这其中有什么矛盾。——“在南海建立一个英国种目前哨站”的人。对此，他毫不掩饰。是的，我是说，我不认为这其中有什么矛盾。我认为他觉得英国在某种程度上背叛了一种信任，或者说仅仅是无力维护这种信任，而美国则是未来的面孔——当然还有大量的义务兵。所以这也是一个问题，那就是柯廷——柯廷最初是通过投票反对征兵而成名的。并且我认为他越来越感觉到，随着澳大利亚
fills up with American conscripts who are defending Australia, it's simply unconscionable for Australia not to have an element of conscription themselves. And so he brings in a law that basically conscription is introduced and that they can be posted outside the limits of Australia if that involves defending Australia. is of Irish Catholic parentage. He has turned his back on the Catholic Church, and not just turned his back, he's stormed out and slammed the door very firmly shut, because they bring him a Catholic priest, don't they, as he's dying, and he doesn't want to know him.
挤满了保卫澳大利亚的美军义务兵，澳大利亚如果没有自己的义务兵制度，简直是说不过去的。因此他引入了一项法律，基本推行了征兵制，并且如果为了保卫澳大利亚，他们可以被派往澳大利亚本土以外的地区。他有着爱尔兰天主教徒的血统。他已经背弃了天主教教会，而且不仅仅是背弃，他是气冲冲地夺门而出，并把门重重地关上，因为当他垂死之际，他们给他找来了一位天主教神甫，不是吗？而他根本不想理睬。
Go away, mate. Is that what he said? Something like that, I imagine. But what's extraordinary is he wouldn't go, he would never set foot in a Catholic church, not even when his friends were getting married he wouldn't go but that's a kind of that's a very catholic form it's very catholic isn't it yeah it is you know yeah yeah i think so anyway he is succeeded by a man who now this is a confession that you know some people will think absolutely damning that he a man who i i learn from online historical rankings
“滚开，老兄。”他是这么说的吗？我想大概类似这样吧。但非同寻常的是，他不会去——他绝不会踏入天主教教堂一步，甚至连他的朋友结婚他都不会去。但那其实是一种非常天主教的形式，非常天主教，不是吗？是的，确实如此，你知道的。是的，我想是的。无论如何，接替他的是一个人——现在这是一个坦白，有些人会认为这简直是罪大恶极——一个我从网上关于澳大利亚前首相历史排名的研究中了解到的男人，
of australian prime ministers of australia from research in the bodleian historians and political scientists i learned by people in the know is regarded as one of australia's absolute greatest prime ministers and until about four hours ago i don't think i'd ever heard of him but don't believe that it's it's so interesting because, of course, he is. I mean, in a way, he's the Clement Attlee. He is. Of Australia. We should tell people who he is because they won't know.
这项研究来自博德利图书馆的历史学家和政治学者，我从知情人士那里了解到，他被认为是澳大利亚最伟大的首相之一。而在大约四个小时前，我觉得我从未听说过这个人。但别怀疑，这太有趣了，因为当然，他就是——从某种意义上说，他就是澳大利亚的克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee）。他确实是的。我们应该告诉大家他是谁，因为他们不会知道。
Okay, so this is Ben Chifley. Ben Chifley, a name to conjure with. Who, again, very like Curtin, is of Irish descent. Yeah, he's from New South Wales, isn't he? He's a Labour Party and he is an engine driver. driver and again i just think it reflects tremendously well in australia that you know an engine driver can we had engine drivers in britain jimmy thomas in the 1930s he didn't become prime minister no he didn't you know our prime minister's went to ethan driver um so um so it's on that he gets involved in the unions and unions are very very strong in australia
好的，这就是本·奇夫利（Ben Chifley）。本·奇夫利，一个名声响亮的名字。他同样和柯廷一样，有着爱尔兰血统。是的，他来自新南威尔士州，对吧？他是工党党员，曾是一名火车司机。而且，我再次认为这极大地反映了澳大利亚的优越之处，你知道，一个火车司机可以——我们在英国也有过火车司机，比如20世纪30年代的吉米·托马斯（Jimmy Thomas），但他并没有当上首相。不，他没有，你知道的，我们的首相都是伊顿公学毕业的司机——所以，他投身于工会运动，而工会在澳大利亚非常非常强大。
yeah um and um he kind of entered he's through the 30s he's um early 30s he's minister of defense and he loses his seat has a really bad great depression um at one point you know he's dependent on his wife's earnings um so has it has it really bad 1940 gets back into parliament by the the following year he's become the treasurer so chancellor of the exchequer equivalent finance minister for curtain um and succeeds curtain and as i say is basically the the clement atlee of australia he's very much about sort of fiscal discipline controls um he's a he's a sort of financial wizard isn't he running the australian economy um but he's also got the austerity of an atlee and they're sort of he's got that sort of that that very mid-century sort of labor party tradition but but austere patriotic kind of man yeah i mean
是的，并且，他在30年代进入政坛——30年代初他是国防部长，然后在大萧条期间失去了席位，遭遇了非常严重的大危机。有一段时间，你知道，他要靠妻子的收入过活，所以他的日子在1940年过得很惨。不过他又回到了议会，第二年他就成了财政大臣——相当于柯廷的财政部长，后来接替了柯廷。正如我所说，他基本上就是澳大利亚的克莱门特·艾德礼。他非常注重财政纪律和管制，他是个金融奇才，对吧，把澳大利亚的经济打理得井井有条；但他身上也有着艾德礼式的紧缩作风，他有着那种世纪中叶工党传统的、简朴而爱国的人的特质。是的，我的意思。
i think the thing that sums him up is this thing about his dinner with the king, George VI. So the king invites him to dinner, doesn't he, Tom? And he can't go because he's got no evening dress. But what happens? The king says that he'll wear a lounge suit. And so Chifley and the king go and nobody else knows this. So the king and Chifley are the only two in lounge suits. I think that's a story that reflects absolutely splendidly on George VI.
我认为最能总结他特质的就是关于他与国王乔治六世共进晚餐的那件事。所以国王邀请他共进晚餐，对吧，汤姆？但他不能去，因为他没有晚礼服。但结果怎么样呢？国王说他可以穿便服去。于是奇夫利和国王就去了，而且没有其他人知道这件事。所以国王和奇夫利是仅有的两个穿便服的人。我觉得这是一个极好地反映了乔治六世风范的故事。
Yes. Colin Firth would love that story. I know. Why didn't they put that in? They should have put that in. Geoffrey Rush could have played Chifley as well, being Australian. So he loses, Tom, in 1949, very similar to Atlee's loss, I suppose, in 1951. Well, he wanted to nationalise the banks.
是的。科林·费斯（Colin Firth）一定会喜欢这个故事。我懂。他们为什么没把它拍进去？他们应该把它拍进去的。雷夫·范恩斯（译者注：原文为Geoffrey Rush，即杰弗里·拉什）也可以演奇夫利，毕竟他是澳大利亚人。所以，汤姆，他在1949年落选了，这有点类似于艾德礼在1951年的落选，我想。嗯，因为他想要将银行国有化。
And that was a step too far. Yes. And by this point, Robert Menzies is back at the head of the Conservative, the right. The Liberal Party, yeah. Well, I don't think it is quite the Liberal Party yet. Is it not the Liberal Party yet? No, because it's all rather confusing.
而那步子迈得太大了。是的。到了这个时候，罗伯特·孟席斯（Robert Menzies）重新回到了保守派、右翼的领导岗位上。自由党，是的。嗯，我觉得当时还不能完全算是自由党吧？还不是自由党吗？不，因为当时情况挺让人迷惑的。
I think it's still the United Australia Party. It's become the Liberal Party. And so he does the kind of anti-communism stuff. He plays that very hard. And so Chifley loses the election. And he's dead within a couple of years. So he dies, Tom, during the dinner that they're having to celebrate the 50th anniversary of the Federation of Australia. And Menzies announces, his rival announces his death in very moving terms he says i've printed
我想当时它还是澳大利亚联合党（United Australia Party）。后来才变成了自由党。所以他大搞反共那一套。他在这方面打得很狠。于是奇夫利输掉了大选。没过几年他就去世了。所以，汤姆，他是在庆祝澳大利亚联邦成立50周年的晚宴上突然去世的。孟席斯宣布了他的死讯——他的政治对手用非常感人的措辞宣布了他的死讯。他说我已经打印
it out very exciting i won't do it and i don't have to do an australian accent because menzies didn't have a very australian accent he said uh it's my very sorrowful duty during this celebration tonight tiny bit of one to tell you that mr chifley has died i don't want to try to talk about him now because although we're political opponents, he was a friend of mine and of yours and a fine Australian. A mate. Yeah. So that's sort of mateship, isn't it? Yeah.
出来了，非常激动人心的内容，我就不照念了。而且我也不用去模仿澳大利亚口音，因为孟席斯本来就没有很重的澳大利亚口音。他说：“在今晚的庆祝活动中，我怀着极其沉痛的心情（带有一点点口音）告诉大家，奇夫利先生已经逝世了。我现在不想过多地谈论他，因为尽管我们曾经是政治对手，但他是我、也是你们的朋友，是一个优秀的澳大利亚人。一个好兄弟（mate）。”是的，这就是那种“兄弟情谊”（mateship），对吧？是的。
You know, we're all kind of great Australians together. And I think that's actually one of the nice things about Australian politics is they love being Australian. Yeah. I mean, everybody's always saying, well, how great it is to be australian deep down we're all australians anyway so um that's the end of chifley he's dead he's gone to top spot he might have had an affair with the secretary she was with him in the hotel and one of his biographers later said that he might have had an affair with her sister as well i know but the but everybody's family everybody's family denied that very
你知道，我们大家都是了不起的澳大利亚人。我觉得这也是澳大利亚政治招人喜欢的一点，他们热爱身为澳大利亚人。是的。我的意思是，每个人总是说，身为澳大利亚人是多么棒的一件事，内心里我们大家其实都是澳大利亚人。所以，这就是奇夫利的故事的结局，他去世了，走上了巅峰。他可能曾与自己的秘书有过一段绯闻，当时她就和他住在同一家酒店里。后来他的传记作家之一还说，他可能也和她的秘书姐姐有过一腿。我知道，但是——但每个人的家庭、每个人的家庭都对此予以了非常
vociferously don't they so so people have listened to our previous podcasts about sort of presidents and so on chancellors so the german one was notable for the behavior of gerhard schroeder and uh the french one for the bad behavior of all of them but the australian one is the such bad behavior is as there is and there will be some bad behaviour to come. It's much more. Yeah. It's small. There's no eating of precious birds or Valerie Giscard d'Estaing.
激烈的否认，不是吗？所以，听过我们之前关于总统、总理等职位的播客的听众应该记得，德国的那期因格哈德·施罗德（Gerhard Schröder）的行为而引人注目，法国的那期则因所有人糟糕的行为而闻名。但澳大利亚这一期——尽管也有一些糟糕的行为，而且接下来还会有一些糟糕的行为——要温和得多。是的。规模较小。这里可没有吃珍稀鸟类这种事，也没有瓦莱里·吉斯卡尔·德斯坦（Valéry Giscard d'Estaing）。
He wouldn't stand a chance. Well, oddly, I mean, you tend to think of Australia as a particularly religious country. But they all were from church-going, very very keen and when they're not church going they're kind of they're priggishly not church going yeah absolutely i think that must be they're either people of faith or they're people who very very vigorously abjured their faith aren't they yes and so essentially are still people of faith yes so anyway menzies has come back and menzies what i found absolutely fascinating about Menzies is Menzies comes back.
他在这里可混不下去。嗯，奇怪的是，你会觉得澳大利亚是一个特别宗教化的国家。但他们所有人都有着上教堂的背景，非常非常热衷于此；而当他们不上教堂时，他们又那种假正经地不去教堂——是的，绝对如此。我想这必然是——他们要么是虔诚的信仰者，要么是那种极其激烈地公开抛弃自己信仰的人，不是吗？是的，所以本质上他们仍然是有信仰的人。是的。无论如何，孟席斯卷土重来了。而孟席斯——我发现关于孟席斯最迷人的一点是，孟席斯又回来了。
And in 1942, he'd given a speech about the forgotten people. Did you see this, Tom? No. So he said in this speech, I do not believe that the real life of this nation is to be found either in great luxury hotels and the petty gossip of so-called fashionable suburbs, or in the officialdom of the organized masses. It is to be found in the homes of people who are nameless and unadvertised, and who, whatever their individual religious conviction or dogma, see in their children
在1942年，他曾发表过一篇关于“被遗忘的人”（The forgotten people）的演讲。你看到过这个吗，汤姆？没有。所以他在演讲中说：“我不认为这个国家真正的生活存在于豪华大酒店和所谓时髦郊区的无聊八卦中，也不存在于有组织的大众官僚体制中。它存在于那些无名无姓、默默无闻的人们的家庭中，无论他们各自的宗教信仰或教条如何，他们在自己的孩子身上看到了
their greatest contribution to the immortality of their race. And this struck a... This was this great speech on the sort of forgotten Australians, And it struck a massive chord with kind of suburban, I guess, middle class voters. And this is, what is it, almost 30 years before Richard Nixon gives his silent majority speech. He coins the phrase, the silent majority. And Menzies is doingen in the post-war years the way in which actually australia kind of blazes trails for both british and american politics yeah and you see this happening again and again and again it's almost like it's a kind of american and british politicians look at it as a kind of laboratory where things are being tested
他们对种族不朽做出的最大贡献。”这打动了……这是关于那种“被遗忘的澳大利亚人”的伟大演讲，它在郊区的中产阶级选民（我猜）中引发了巨大的共鸣。这距离理查德·尼克松发表“沉默的大多数”演讲早了差不多30年。他创造了“沉默的大多数”这个词。而孟席斯在战后年代就已经在这么做了，实际上澳大利亚为英国和美国的政治开辟了先河。是的，你会一次又一次地看到这种情况发生。这几乎就像是一个实验室，美英两国的政治家们把它看作是一个测试各种新事物的实验室。
out i completely and that's a kind of you know things are being tested out. I completely agree. And that's a kind of, you know, intriguing example. I think perhaps because it's a, you know, it's a very suburban society, Australia, isn't it? Becoming a very suburban society in the mid-century and sort of 50s, 60s. And it's sort of anticipating the suburban politics that you'll see, let's say Margaret Thatcher, that she does with her appeal to kind of home ownership
我完全赞同。这是一个——你知道的——耐人寻味的例子。我想也许是因为澳大利亚是一个非常郊区化的社会，对吧？在世纪中叶以及50年代、60年代逐渐变成了一个高度郊区化的社会。它某种程度上预示了你后来会在玛格丽特·撒切尔身上看到的郊区政治——她通过诉诸房屋所有权等来赢得支持。
and stuff. Yeah. And I think that rather like uh you know hippies see nixon as the embodiment of everything that they hate um you know oppressive stuffy parochial um people young intellectuals in australia see menzies in similar way so and why, you know, all the kind of the big names who come to England, so Clive James and Jermaine Greer and Barry Humphreys, essentially what they're fleeing is Menzies and everything that he embodies.
是的。并且我认为，就像嬉皮士视尼克松为他们所痛恨的一切的化身一样——你知道的，那些压抑的、死板的、狭隘的东西——澳大利亚年轻的知识分子也以同样的方式看待孟席斯。所以——为什么所有那些去英国的大人物，比如克莱夫·詹姆斯（Clive James）、日耳曼·格里尔（Jermaine Greer）和巴里·汉弗莱斯（Barry Humphreys），他们本质上逃离的正是孟席斯以及他所化身的一切。
The irony being, of course, is that, you know, they're fleeing the Anglophile Menzies to come to London. Yeah, that's right. Well, they're fleeing the sort of the the the australian affluent society to some extent aren't they complacent conservative affluent society yeah and a kind of um censoriousness so there was a kind of famous case where um a a cafe named the moulin rouge um in sydney was fined for having um on the cafe wall a copy of toulouse-latrecq's woman adjusting her stocking and this was condemned as obscene so i mean that's why
当然，这里的讽刺之处在于，你知道的，他们逃离了亲英的孟席斯，结果却是为了来到伦敦。是的，没错。嗯，他们某种程度上是在逃离澳大利亚富裕的社会，不是吗？自满、保守的富裕社会。是的，还有那种盛气凌人的审查制度。所以当时有一个著名的案例，悉尼一家名为“红磨坊”（Moulin Rouge）的咖啡馆因为在咖啡馆墙上挂了一张图卢兹-劳特累克（Toulouse-Lautrec）的《正在整理长袜的女人》的复制品而被罚款，这被谴责为淫秽。所以我的意思是，难怪
jmangria would obviously put up with that um so famously jean shrimpton pioneered was said to a pioneer the mini skirt i think that's actually an exaggeration at melbourne a melbourne race course and the matrons of melbourne were horrified that she had a mini dress, I think it actually was, that went above her, that stopped at the knee, and you could see the bottom of her legs. So there is a sort of conservatism. I mean, as well as it's egalitarian, and it has very strong trade unions and a welfare state, there is a kind of moral conservatism. Yes, and I think the strength of that left-wing tradition is what makes the anti-Marxist tradition correspondingly strong. And that's what Menzies plugs into, and he's always invoking it.
日耳曼·格里尔会对此感到无法忍受。同样出名的还有让·什里普顿（Jean Shrimpton），据说她率先引领了迷你裙的风潮——我觉得这其实有点夸张——是在墨尔本的一个赛马场上，而墨尔本的贵妇们被吓坏了，因为她穿了一件迷你裙（我觉得实际上确实是），裙摆一直高过膝盖，还能看到她的小腿根部。所以这里确实存在一种保守主义。尽管它崇尚平等主义，拥有非常强大的工会和福利国家，但也存在一种道德上的保守主义。是的，而且我认为这种左翼传统的强大，恰恰造就了相应强大的反马克思主义传统。这也是孟席斯所契合的，他一直在呼吁这一点。
And so there's a famous – so he's up for re-election in 1954. And what crash lands into the course of that election election which it looks like menzies is going to lose is probably australia's most famous spy scandal the petrov affair it's a great affair this if you're going to have a fabulous spy scandal this is this yes so um petrov was he was vladimir petrov he was a kgb officer um and he's hanging out in uh in sydney and he decides that you know australia australia is a lot nicer than uh moscow yeah why didn't the order fact yeah he decides to jump ship so he says i no longer believe in communism since i have seen the australian way of living but he doesn't tell his wife and once he's defected the uh kind of soviet goons bundle her onto a plane in the full
于是有一个著名的事件——他在1954年面临连任竞选。而正当这场看似孟席斯会输掉的大选进行得如火如荼之际，什么事情突如其降了呢？这可以说是澳大利亚最著名的间谍丑闻——彼得罗夫事件（The Petrov Affair）。这是一桩惊天大案，如果你要找一桩精彩绝伦的间谍丑闻，那就是这个了，是的。所以彼得罗夫——他是弗拉基米尔·彼得罗夫（Vladimir Petrov），一名克格勃军官。他在悉尼厮混，然后他决定——澳大利亚比莫斯科要美好得多。是的，为什么不呢？
view of australian cameras and and they're all appalled by this and this plane has to refuel darwin and australian secret service agents managed to get her off the plane um and obviously this is you know damsel in distress evil communists it's brilliant and it enables menzies to overcome the odds and to win the election and so there's been this grumbling conspiracy theory that menzies timed the announcement of petrov's defection to sway the election and maybe he did i mean well i i who knows? He'd be a fool if he didn't. Well, I gather from my extensive research into this, the consensus is that it wasn't Menzies who did this,
他决定反水。于是他说：“自从我见识了澳大利亚的生活方式后，我不再相信共产主义了。”但他没有告诉他的妻子。在他叛逃后，苏联的爪牙们在澳大利亚摄像机的众目睽睽之下，硬把她塞上了一架飞机。所有人都对此感到震惊。这架飞机不得不在达尔文降落加油，而澳大利亚秘密特工设法将她弄下了飞机。显然，这就是——落难少女大战邪恶共产主义者，太精彩了。这使得孟席斯力挽狂澜赢得了大选。因此，一直有一种阴谋论在流传，认为孟席斯精心算好了宣布彼得罗夫叛逃的时机来左右大选。也许他真的这么做了。嗯，谁知道呢？如果他没这么做，那他就是个傻瓜。嗯，从我对这件事进行的广泛研究来看，共识并不是孟席斯策划了这一切，
but it's possible that the Australian Secret Service ensured that the timing would be right. The big question, though, Tom, is what did Vladimir Petrov think? I mean, he might not have told his wife. I know a i know people think he didn't tell his wife because he couldn't afford that she would tell somebody or she would persuade him out of it or didn't want to implicate her but i mean he might have been gutted when the australians pitched up and said we've got your wife mate yeah you might well have been again if there are if there are experts in the petrov affair who can tell us how petrov and his wife got on after the defection, I'd be very interested to know about that.
但澳大利亚秘密特工有可能确保了时机的恰到好处。不过，汤姆，最大的问题是，弗拉基米尔·彼得罗夫是怎么想的？我的意思是，他可能真的没告诉妻子。我认识一些人认为他没告诉妻子是因为他冒不起险，怕她走漏风声，或者劝他打消念头，又或者他不想把她牵连进来。但我的意思是，当澳大利亚人找上门来说“老兄，我们把你老婆接出来了”时，他可能肠子都悔青了。是的，他很可能真的很懊恼。如果有人是彼得罗夫事件的专家，能告诉我们彼得罗夫和他的妻子在叛逃后相处得怎么样，我会有极大的兴趣了解一下。
But basically, this has quite a knock on effect because essentially it bakes in anti-communism as a key part of Menzies appeal to the people who voted for him. And so therefore, he's very, very keen to play the anti-communist card. And with Vietnam starting to kind of bubble up to the north of Australia, this is why Menzies essentially signs Australia up to the Vietnam War. And in fact, he's so keen to do it that he fabricates an invitation from the South Vietnamese government asking for Australian troops. They never did this. Well, I mean, the Australians, if you believe in the domino theory, which so many people did in the 1950s and 60s, which is that one state after another would fall to communism. And as one went, then its neighbor would be the next in line.
但基本上，这件事产生了相当大的连锁反应，因为它本质上将反共主义固化为了孟席斯争取选民支持的核心手段。因此，他非常非常热衷于打反共牌。随着越南局势开始在澳大利亚北部酝酿升温，这就是孟席斯让澳大利亚加入越战的根本原因。事实上，他如此急于这样做，以至于他伪造了一份来自南越政府的邀请函，请求澳大利亚出兵。他们根本没发过这封信。好吧，我是说，澳大利亚人——如果你相信“多米诺骨牌理论”（这是50时间和60年代许多人的坚信不疑的理论，即一个接一个的国家会陷入共产主义，随着一个倒下，其邻国就会成为下一个）。
I mean, the last dominoes are Australia and New Zealand. And there must have been an awful lot of people in Australia who were extremely anxious that as they as they look as they look to their kind of northwest yeah that the the tide of communism especially if they as you said at the beginning if they're already believing that they're living next door to this sort of this great yeah yeah sort of pestilential yeah you know disease-ridden pit as they see so i'm sure that's a part of it as well and i'm sure also it's itential, you know, disease ridden pit as they see. So I'm sure that's a part of it as well.
那么，最后倒下的多米诺骨牌就是澳大利亚和新西兰。当时澳大利亚肯定有相当多的人极其焦虑，当他们望向自己的西北方向时，看到共产主义的浪潮——尤其是如果像你刚才在开头所说的那样，他们本来就觉得自己生活在这样一个——这样一个巨大的、充满瘟疫的粪坑隔壁。所以，我确信这也是其中的一部分，而且我确信它也是——
And I'm sure also it's, it's about, you know, it's following on from Curtin's declaration that they're now going to look to the United States, that Australia is now playing the role to the United States. It is a previously played to Britain of, of, you know,
充满瘟疫的粪坑。所以，我确信这也是其中的一部分。而且我也确信，这延续了柯廷的宣言，即他们现在要将目光投向英国曾经扮演的角色——
mateship. Yes. Geopolitical mateship signing up to help. Well, so, so, so Menzies gets Australia intoralia into the vietnam war he uh but he's i mean he he interesting he is he is the guy who starts the dismantling of the white
地缘政治上的兄弟情谊，签署协议提供援助。所以，所以，所以孟席斯让澳大利亚卷入了越南战争。他——不过他的趣事在于，他其实是那个开始拆除“白澳政策”的人。所以他开启了移民改革。是的。而且他——我认为他是一个相当有原则的人。他极具才华，不贪婪，就个人而言，他是一个堂堂正正的澳大利亚人。是的，他是个堂堂正正、光明磊落的人。但我的意思是，如果你是一个澳大利亚人——如果你像你说的，是日耳曼·格里尔之类的人，他就是你所痛恨的一切，绝对是你所痛恨的一切。并且我认为他确实带有一种略显滑稽的亲英虚荣心。所以当他在1966年卸任时，他接替丘吉尔成了五港总督（Warden of the Cinque Ports）。你知道的，听过我们和亚历克斯·普雷斯顿（Alex Preston）关于走私的节目的听众会知道，这是英格兰东南部的一组中世纪港口联盟。他是负责带头打击走私犯的吗？是的，他确实是。而且有一套了不起的制服，
australia policy so he starts immigration reform yeah uh and he's um i mean i think he's a he's a pretty principled man um he's very intellectually able he's he's he's not greedy he's a kind of personally you know he's um he's an upstanding australian yeah he's an upstanding upstanding but i mean if you're an australian sort of if you're as you say if you're jermaine greer or whatever he's everything you'd hate you absolutely everything you'd hate and i think he does have a slightly comical strain of anglophile vanity so when he um he steps down in uh in 1966 he he succeeds churchill as warden of the sink ports you know which people who listen to the the episode we did with alex preston on smuggling on smuggling um this is a kind of medieval consortium of ports in the southeast of england he's leading the fight against smugglers is he yes he is and there's a tremendous uniform
你知道的，包括滑稽的帽子，非常非常——我觉得给我的印象是，孟席斯最快乐的时候就是穿着五港总督制服的时候。他算是体面地退场了。汤姆，他的最后几次重大公开露面之一，可以说是英澳关系的完美写照，不是吗？那是1977年，百年灰烬杯，百年对抗赛。墨尔本板球场（MCG）的百年对抗赛，是的。他在MCG的长房间里被女王授予爵位，MCG就是墨尔本板球场。
you know that involves comical hats and like very very and i think i get the impression you get the impression that menzies is never happier than when he's dressed up as um in his wharton of the sink port well he sort of bows out his. One of his last great sort of public appearances, Tom, could not be more Anglo-Australian relations, could it? So it's 1977, the centenary ashes, the centenary test. The centenary test in the MCG, yeah. And he's knighted by the Queen in the long room of the MCG, which is the Melbourne Cricket Ground.
是的。我的意思是，获得爵位的方式简直绝了。你一定用绝对羡慕的眼光来看待这件事。我真的非常羡慕。真的非常羡慕。而且他热爱古老的板球场。所以他就是那个将劳兹板球场（Lord's）称为“板球大教堂”的人。所以，是的。
Yeah. I mean, what a way to get a knighthood. You must look on that with absolute envy. I really do. I really do. And he loved old cricket grounds. So he's the guy who described Lourdes as the cathedral of cricket. So, yeah.
在太多方面，他就是你心目中暗地里想成为的那种人。暗地里。是的，暗地里。我很想当五港总督，然后在板球馆里被女王授予爵位。所以，听着，我们离原计划在这第一期播客里达到的进度差得还挺远，因为我们才刚讲到1966年。
So in so many ways. He's the man you wanted to be. Secretly. Yeah. Secretly. I'd love to be warden of the St. Ports and be knighted by the Queen in a cricket pavilion. So, listen, we've fallen quite short of where we were intending to get to with this first podcast, because we've only got to 1966.
不过没关系，因为我们——是的，我们还有很多关于澳大利亚前首相的精彩故事要讲。是的，而且都很有趣。所以，我想我们现在就休会，去喝杯茶什么的，然后我们会回来。汤姆，哈罗德·霍尔特（Harold Holt）将作为开场击球手。是的，他——我们可不想用游泳的比喻来形容他怎么——是的，是的。
But that's fine, because we're... Yeah, we've got a lot of Aussie primaniceness to come. Yeah. And they're all good fun. So, I think we will adjourn now uh for tea as it were and we will and we will return um uh tom will harold holt will be opening the batting yes he gets we don't want a swimming analogy for how yes yes. So yes, Harold Holt will open the innings tomorrow and I have to say it gets dismissed quite quickly and in very, very controversial circumstances and leaves behind,
所以，是的，哈罗德·霍尔特明天将为比赛开局，而且我必须说，他很快就被三振出局了，而且是在非常非常富有争议的情况下，留下的纪念碑——坦白说，可以说是相当非同寻常。但如果你想了解更多信息，请明天收听。再见！再见！感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告畅听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
frankly, quite extraordinary memorial. But if you want to find out more about that, tune in tomorrow. Good day. Good day. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告畅听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请访问 therestisentertiment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。